Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burr and his time for the
Monday morning podcast for Monday,
May 9th,
2016 what's going on?
How you throw in there?
Fuckos um,
oh, freckles laying on his back
trying to get rid of the Sayada cuts.
Much better SCIATICA.
Oh, cy. Anika,
a lot of people don't know that was the
original lyrics to Panama. You know,
David Lee wanted to say,
you know,
Sciatica and Eddie wanted to an Alex
wanted Panama and Michael Anthony,
he's like, come on guys. You know,
except he said it in a much higher voice.
Can we fucking just get along here?
And David ended up giving in to
the brothers and that's what it,
next thing you know, he was
on his own. I'm just a Gigolo.
So, um, yeah, my back is
doing, it's doing much better.
Slowly but surely I've,
I've kind of found out that it's going
to sort of work itself out if I just
don't have to sit on my fucking ass from
here to Jacksonville every other week.
But that's the life that I live,
you know,
it's just the weirdest injury ever.
Usually if you're fucked up, sitting down,
you know, and resting is a good thing.
This thing I just got to kind of, uh,
lay down.
I'm a mess.
I'm taking that fucking Ibu pro.
I don't even, what the fuck it is.
Some anti-inflammatory thing.
I'm stretching like a fucking NHL goalie,
trying to get everything all fucking
undone down there, but I don't,
I don't know what's going on. I don't
know. But it is a, it is getting better.
But I,
um,
I flew all the way back
today from Jacksonville. Uh,
had a great time. And by the
way, here's, here's some, uh,
here's some advice for you when you're
out on the road and you're going to get a
breakfast.
All right?
Unless you're in some mom and pop place
and he could see over the counter,
you can watch them making your food, which
I don't necessarily really like to do.
If you're gonna order eggs,
don't ever order scrambled eggs.
I know what you're thinking. Why,
Bill? Why, why wouldn't you do that?
Cause they got a giant fucking VAT
that they've made scrambled eggs or the
fucking oatmeal of eggs when he
go to restaurants. It's just,
it's like the trail is Anya. It's
just that is you fucking, you know,
is your fucking eggs.
Especially like this morning,
the place where I went to Jacksonville,
he ate at the Chili's restaurant in
Jacksonville, Florida. I know you guys.
You're jealous, right? Oh my
God. He gets to see everything.
So me and Forrest Shah who
murdered it all week, um,
we ordered the,
the whatever,
the American breakfast or something there
and your only option on the eggs was
scrambled. Okay. Now if that's
the fucking case, that means they
got a giant VAT that was probably made,
I don't know how long ago,
whatever the health code violation
is plus five minutes, you know,
it's been sitting. So you get the
rubber fucking eggs and then bacon,
they just make a bunch of fucking bacon.
They got that sit to the side,
you know,
and then they had to have bullshit
Hash browns, which you know,
was already all the whole
fucking thing was already made.
The only thing that really
tasted good was the biscuit.
So, um, if you ever at
the airport, you know,
or if you're going down to the hotel
lobby for their continental breakfast,
um,
you always never would have scrambled
eggs or eggs over easy, get an Omelet,
you know,
um,
do something like that where they just
aren't going to just have the shit
already made. Um, or you could
do the gross shit with the syrup,
but that's going to fuck
your whole day up. I feel,
I mean now like I didn't
order a big salty breakfast,
but for some reason a salty
breakfast is as bad as it is.
I can continue to function.
But if you get a waffle or pancakes or
French toast to that shit, you know,
you might as well just have somebody
puts you in a fucking sleeper hold.
Cause cause you're going down
and you're going down early. Um,
so anyway, just a little
travel tip for you there. Um,
so anyways, you know, all this
past week, uh, the lovely Nia,
my beautiful wife was away and I was
telling you how immaculate I was keeping
this place fucking immaculate.
All right.
And um,
okay.
I literally like there was no
trash in any of the barrels.
All the fucking pillows were poofed up,
looked like it looks like a show
room. The living room. Right.
I made the fucking bed,
you know, it was spotless.
I wiped down my side of the fucking sick,
you know,
brushing my teeth and all
that shit spotless. Okay.
I got a car washed and waxed, filled
it up with gas, all of that shit.
Yeah.
Everything was done. Went through
all the bills, got the junk mail,
all the bullshit,
the recycling fucking everything.
Yeah.
I did everything right. So I'm thinking
she's going to come home, you know,
cause I was leaving and
right as I was leaving,
she was coming home so he
would just missing, yeah,
each other.
Right.
So I was thinking when she came
home she was going to be like,
like, Oh man, you know what? I might
have to bring her in for this shit.
You know what, I'm going to have to bring
them in for this. Hang on one second.
Hold on one second.
Hi. All right, so I'm back here. So
anyways, let me keep setting this up.
So my whole thing,
Nia,
was that when you came home, this place
was going to be absolutely spotless.
So you'd be like, oh
my God, that's so nice.
And then also you wouldn't feel like I
was just hopeless SAP without you because
that always bugs me.
Like when women go like tag take tiff,
they fall apart without
us. Like, like I've
never said that about,
you know,
or if I ever thought that I've never
come home after being away and the place
has been in shambles because you don't
know what to do. So I don't know why, you
know,
but you keep holding on to some idea of,
of something that was
talking to them like,
man spreading.
I gotta be on the fucking couch.
Um, no, I don't know what you're
so concerned about that for.
I like the place has never been disgusting
or gross after I have gone away.
So I don't know why you have this
big hangup about, you know, I don't,
I don't get it. You know
what? No, I don't either.
Well I'm trying to think where you fucking
relax and will be worked through my
shit. No. Okay. Sorry. What a jerk.
You're telling this story
and then you're out law.
So any don't like, cause I'm told
what happened. So I'm fucking wait,
I'm on the road on the road again
and I'm in fucking Hollywood,
Florida right at all. I'm thinking is, aw,
the text message I'm going to
get. Oh, it looks so great.
It's so wonderful to come
home to a nice clean house.
It looks like a fucking show room.
And what do I get?
I get a fucking video tape from you.
She's in the pantry now. Evidently
something went bad in the pantry. Okay.
Something didn't go bad in the pantry is
just some shit that's going down to the
pantry. There's some shit going down
to the pantry. So here's the deal.
I'm fucking done in the
pantry. Um, I'm here by myself.
I'm writing on the fucking show every
night until seven o'clock at night.
I come home, my brain is fried. I come
home, I owe to a pizza, I pour a scotch,
I eat,
and then I stare at the wall.
I go to bed and I get right back up and
we stare at the next draft in the next
script. That's been my life. So
I didn't in defense of me. Okay.
The one fucking place I didn't go into.
So it was a pantry.
There was the pantry and stuff
saying, hey, I like that word.
I just realized Pantry pantry stuff saying
I don't like it. Just, it's, I dunno,
it's too close to panties in this I
don't like good food and sex are combined
now. I know you don't like
that. You can't treat, oh,
that nine and a half weeks when he was
fucking her with all the groceries on her,
I just was like, either
eat or fuck, not together,
you know. So anyways. Um,
so she sends me this
video, she's like, Bebe,
how did you not see this?
Right.
It just starts fucking given me all this
shit. I'm like, what the fuck? All right.
And she pans up to the top of the fucking
ceiling and there was, what was it?
There's the larvae. Larvae.
Little, yeah, little moths.
Modal go. It's an inside joke.
Oh, go ahead and side with who?
But the fucking people listening
to, Oh, and I want to do,
no. Yeah, there's sort of larvae.
There's mods and stuff. Because some,
like if there's flour that's been opened,
it's not sealed up properly.
Or grains or cereal,
they'll create little mobs.
Like if you have fruit out for too long,
it'll make fruit flies.
So that was what was happening.
Fruit flies. It attracts them. No,
it creates them from that. I was just
talking to the Terminex guy about it.
They just, they, I don't know what
flies come from. Apples listened. Yeah.
Like if you have fruit and
stuff out to orange, apple,
and then fucking nine months later you
get a fruit fly. You're like, there's no,
there's no woman there that's making an
apple. No Bill. That's not what I mean.
It's not a fruit having sex.
That's what you're saying.
You're saying that I'm saying
they I pleasant. I don't know.
I'm not a fucking terminex person,
but he was helping me dirty mobs.
Fuck on those apples
out in the orchard now.
And they plant their seed in there and
then it comes out like alien. Okay.
There's not any fruit in the pantry.
Okay.
So we have grains and he's just
staring at your crash right now.
It's so comfortable that my lower
back is so comfortable right now.
Oh, you know what? I figured out a thing
to get for you for that. But anyway,
we'll get back to that.
But if you have grains and cereals
out exposed and like this little close
environment where it gets warm,
it produces these larvae and
little flies and mobs and shit.
So that's what the guy just told me.
He's not saying it right.
Well how are you saying?
Are you saying?
I'm saying please like tell me how you
explain things and how clear it is when
you explain things.
What I would say is like,
you know if you're having a
cookout and you'll leave food out,
all of a sudden flies or an ant show up,
but they don't come from the food.
That's what he told me.
I'll be,
you keep saying they coming from
the apples and it's confusing me.
You said it came from apples.
I said nothing about it
came from Amarillo line this from apples.
I would never say it came for you.
The start throwing apples into the mix.
I was trying to explain to
you about grains and shit.
I was saying it's like
fruit flies in school.
I can't even hear what you're
saying because you don't listen.
That's why you got damn add. You
don't listen. You don't listen.
And he started saying things and you
said them and then you attribute them to
the other person.
Like it's so confusing to talk to you
sometimes because you don't let it. Oh,
it's so fucking hard.
It is hard.
How about we were just watching the
Simpsons and you watch the entire episode
and midway through it you were like,
why is that happening? And I'm like,
where did the blue snake,
like a major plot point that hadn't
been explained not even five minutes
earlier, but you don't pay
attention. How about this?
How about my fucking back is out and I
was in Jacksonville, Florida this morning.
How about that? What does that have to do
with anything that we're talking about?
Well, maybe I'm a little fucking, you
know, not focusing on a fucking cartoon.
Okay. You're going to such a baby when
you traveled to it. Whenever you travel,
you fucking for like one day like
Guma good. I do know how you do this.
And then it goes right out your
fucking head. And then the next,
next time I'm coming back off the
road, you like, oh, let's go. Uh,
you know Susie Fricker sees having a
fucking who hard down the fucking street.
You want to go to that when I say no,
you flip out at me and I don't know
what you're talking about. Shit.
Do you know exactly when you know who
she is to see the frequency? Oh yeah,
he's that bright. All
right, so what happened?
So she comes home and evidently there's
some sort of bug horror movie and you
know how, what infestation infestation.
And you know how the Lady's react.
They don't like insects.
You know what I mean?
They don't like insects the way men don't
like cats hate those fucking things.
There's nothing better than a cool cat.
I like a cool cat that chills
and lays in the fucking sun.
You know I liked her. A new Chris.
You? Yeah, I don't like that.
And when they're practicing killing it,
you just look over and they're
staring at you from the corner now.
Then they stop and try and play it
off. I don't like, I don't like that.
They stand on your chest in the morning,
waking you up.
I don't think they shit in a box.
And then like you gotta pick it up.
It's just too much. It's too much
cleo shit. So it just outside.
But we still gotta pick it up.
I know, but I don't have to,
it's not in the house checking on me.
If you're going to shit in the house,
go in the toilet.
I think some people can train
their cats to shit in the toilet.
I don't know how, but, well,
I can tell you how they can't
communicate with other human beings.
So they put all their energy into yeah,
like they, they got like that gift.
They have like a,
like an Asperger
Aspbergers with cat. Some sort of, um,
what's that thing they're always talking
about nowadays? Autism. Autism. Yeah.
Like autistic with people.
But communicate with cats.
Stop what the like play an instrument
stop with no one in his diagnosis of the
mental illnesses. It's just dope.
Just stop right there please.
He's talking about Ben. Are you going
to get angry tweets? I'm not mocking,
mocking any of that.
I'm making fun of people that put,
you can't fucking say anything anymore.
Everybody gets all worried. Oh, I know.
I do benefits for all of those things.
All of those things I know about
my free fucking all in black.
Oh Jesus Christ.
Ah,
I remember when things were funny.
Oh,
it was so simple back
in the day where it was,
you could change things and
never a fucking jerk off.
Didn't have some way that they could
just spout about up fucking annoyed they
are, but everything else is fine as long
as it doesn't come around to my world.
Can I just ask what the situation
is here with the Ziploc bag?
What about it and how you're
keeping your equipment stored? Yeah.
Bill's got this cord and the little
foamy part that you put on, uh,
the wind screen,
the windscreen and a couple of batteries
and an old Ziploc bag that's ripped and
just doesn't even zip anymore.
Right.
So I'm just wondering why basically,
because it, it still holds the things
and if I just throw that thing out,
another one's going to break and then
that thing right there is probably going
to end up on the nose of a porpoise
and it's not gonna be able to eat.
It's going to die because everything
ends up in the ocean. Yeah. You know,
they say that put litter in its place.
It's like the second,
all this shit that you throw out the
same. You don't pollute. We all pollute.
It's just some of us do take
this on the road with it.
It's not like I was having an
idea that good. I mean you,
I take it on the role that you're
just going to be like a babbling about
something that you don't
really know about us. I mean,
I don't really feel that's the
charm of the testing. Anything. Uh,
so you take this on the road with
you? Yes. All right. Well I was just,
I couldn't give you a nice
leather Satchel. Really?
You got a skin of fucking
cow because I already,
I already have one no last longer than
putting it in this ridiculous thing
that's never going to biodegrade.
What's this bad thing?
And that thing won't biodegrade fat that
they will be here somewhere in the dark
somewhere hundreds of fucking years after
we're gone saying you can have a nice
way to carry your things.
It doesn't look like you know the bag
that we should use for sandwiches.
What is your fascination
with just like buying shit,
but what do you mean fascination
with buying ships session?
I mean, look at this.
Look at this,
that you're carrying this thing and I
really wish you guys could see the Ziploc
bag right now. It's, it's a mess.
A man of your stature should not be
carrying around your podcast equipment and
an oil past zip lock bag.
A man of my stature.
Fucking two seconds ago I
was a fucking moron. You can
meet. But now, now cause you
to Shay from naenae.
So who do you like tonight?
Who We got Louis Blues
meet me in St Louis.
Louis v versus who?
The Dallas Stars.
Formerly the Minnesota North Stars.
Are these hockey teams? Yes they are.
If they're not like the kings or
the a Bruins, I don't really know.
Oh yeah. What are your feelings
about the kings and the Bruins? Well,
if it came down to it, I would be a
Bruins fan because I'm from Boston.
So are you just saying, are you
gonna root for yeah, but the other,
the rest of them, I don't know.
Those are my two. What do you like?
I like both teams,
but I just,
I started polling for the blues because
the blues have been in the league since
1960. [inaudible] who's getting hook?
Cause the Bruins didn't make the playoffs.
So I was like,
all right,
I got to pick somebody and I'm not going
to jump on the Black Hawks and kings
bandwagon because they're always in it.
So I'm going to go for sewer an underdog.
And I was like, wow. The Blues,
they've been around since 1967
so the Minnesota north stars,
but the people in Dallas
haven't been rooting that long.
But I really liked the players and shit.
I like, I like Dallas, but I, I've,
I've ever been written for um,
a babbling over here looking at it.
But yeah, St Louis, they're going to
be relaxed. They're going to be a,
a kings game that we can go to
cause I really enjoy going to that.
Those two kings games we went to,
they got bounced up. That done.
What do you mean bounced out bay? Uh, they
got beaten by the San Jose Sharks. Oh,
so they're not in it.
It's over. So for them,
the Stanley Cup playoffs, there you go.
They got, they lost in the first round.
What about the breweries? We
didn't make it. We were all,
well then I don't we we overtime,
well we over achieved throughout the
year because at least as far as I was
concerned, but guided we'll do, fuck am I,
but I mean with the players that we
had and every that we got rid of,
I thought we were just gonna be trying
to figure out who the fuck everybody was
for half the season. And
then maybe you know, I dunno.
What about the Toronto Blue Jays and
what happened was we were going to be
making the playoffs and
everybody's all bunched together.
We look a fucking third seat.
Then we'd had a west coast trip and we
got to fucking asses kicked and a and all
went away and it flyer and red
wings fans talk shit about,
you know how high you didn't
make the playoffs and they
both got the right there.
Fred in the first fucking
round. So I enjoyed that. Okay.
Well the Toronto Blue Jays,
is that a, is that a hockey
team? Nope, that's baseball.
Oh, the Toronto Maple leafs.
The amount of the maple leafs got the
first pick in the draft of the raptors.
Are they have a hockey team? Nope.
What were they? Basketball team.
Oh Jesus keeps, keeps
saying this shit. You know.
And then I'll do pick you pick something
else that I don't know anything about.
We'll see who's more. Right. What
do you went to that you know about?
Did I just say that question? What
are you going to, what you know about,
I don't know. Fashion. Okay, go ahead. Um,
oh Jesus. What's the name of the
guy who makes fun of fat people?
He used to be fat.
Ah.
Is that, that's, that's not Alexander
Wang, is it? No. Is that Michael Richards?
Is it Michael?
A Michael Kors?
No, he's German. Is it Paul Mitchell.
And he is the head of a very,
very like the most famous
fashion house in the world.
It's not for Saatchi cause
he got shot by that guy. Yes.
No, it's not the Chanel. Cause that
was a chick and she's dead right.
But she has an apartment in Paris that
you can go into if you're skinny enough.
Right. But you're, you're close.
You're getting that Chanel is right.
Chanel's the right fashion house.
A person who you're talking about is that
the cad creative director for Chanel?
He looks like a war criminal, right?
He's chairman. I'll say you go
and why would they war
criminals via cause they lost.
You would have just as many people going
to fucking Nuremberg really would've.
Okay. Dresden, Karl Lagerfeld. Ah Fuck.
Remember when we saw him and the last
time we were in Paris and the cab and I
started freaking out because I had saw
Carl was walking down the street in Paris
and I thought it was a cool
looking dude, man. He's a vampire,
a vampire war criminal,
old queen looking dude.
Pretty much. That's him.
Name a sports team. Go ahead.
Um, I'll name one of
you. Tell me what it is.
They are the yellow jackets
somebody or did I make that up?
Yellow check.
I feel like that was a high school.
I feel like that was a fucking
fusion band. Um, what about no,
it wasn't his,
that's like wake forest or something.
That's a college basketball team.
Some sort of jackets.
The Grizzlies Grizzlies
to right now Michigan,
it's some place cold that would
have grizzly bears. Right.
So it's not going to be a southern
union. Good guests. But they moved.
They were initially, they were
initially in very cool. Oh, okay.
Is there a Midwestern kind of thing?
They were initially in Vancouver and then
they went to another and Memphis. Oh,
that said the Memphis
Grizzlies for some dumb reason,
they kept the name kind of like when
the New Orleans jazz moved to Utah.
The widest fucking place ever.
Like you'll never see any
jazz or hear any jazz in Utah?
I wouldn't think so.
They are no jazz clubs and Utah.
It's like the New Orleans Mormons,
New Orleans Mormon.
I like that name better.
All right, well we enjoyed you hear
neo. Oh, I'm done. I don't know.
Your phone's ringing. Oh
God. Oh look at us. I know.
I get a call her back.
Um, are you down with me?
Are you wrapping up the podcast?
Did you answer questions? No,
but you can come back to that.
She kind of tired.
So I think I'm going to leave
Oh, down. Nice reversal.
I kicked you off and then you're
like, no, let me come back.
And then you tell me to go fuck
myself. You know what? I enjoy that.
I respect that. So I just came on. It's
how the larvae, larvae, larvae and then,
and get out of here so I could straighten
out my legs and fucking get my,
I feel like Kennedy,
right.
Are you even able to do a podcast
and the upright position anymore? Um,
this is why I married you because it's
the type of compassion that I've come to
expect from you. You're
such a fucking baby. I,
I tough my way through all of this
shit. I never, I never see doctors.
I don't take medicine. That's cause
you're dumb. You're dumb. Well,
it's because I grew up so
people don't go to the hospital.
They don't go to doctors. They will
take medicine. No, you're dumb.
We have advances in our society. I
am dumb, but I'm tougher than you.
You're a baby.
So fine.
Be tough all you want but like be smart
and tough goal to the doctor if you're
so tough. Go to the doctor and
hear what they have to say.
Like after school special. Yeah, I,
well I'm getting there beats up by going
to the doctor and hearing what they
have to say. That's real toughness.
That's real talk. That's real socks on.
All right. I'm out of
here. Nini out. Sorry.
I had to uh,
I enjoyed when you come out.
I miss you baby. Huh? All
right, good. Don't say, Huh?
You heard me listen, I went out. You know,
you know why you don't go to fucking
doctors and all that shit. Why?
Because doctors, they practice
medicine. They practice on you.
They don't have shit down.
And one of the,
one of the things that they still
don't know a lot about this,
but it's not like they don't
mean it like they're practicing.
Like you sit in here practicing drums,
you know,
that's not the same thing they went
to medical school. I understand that.
So why are you like taking that word?
So literally,
have you ever seen Lars Ulrich
play life and he practices,
he fucks up all the time with
Metallica. Oh my God, Nia.
I'm telling you if that's what it means,
you practice medicine and then
you learn off other people.
Just look how much
better hair plugs of God.
Look how much better they are
getting with the fucking, you know,
cut and part of your eye out
and then he can see better.
You told me you were going to go to a
doctor to figure out what was happening
with your leg. Okay. So I know,
I know you think you know what it is,
but can you please go to a doctor and
so it doesn't become a chronic issue.
And then when you're, you know, 50 which
is, can I, can I finish it far away?
Can I finish? You can have some
sort of handle on it. Yeah.
One of the things that they know
the least about is the back. Okay.
And I'm just, I'm just not going to
just go to a fucking chiropractor.
I'm going to find somebody you know
who has a good reputation of not just
fucking opening people up like a fun.
It isn't fine cause I wasn't done talking.
You always jump in because
you're suggesting that I
just want you to go to some
random ass clinic. I was just
joking around. I was joking around.
I'm holding you to this because
you said you were going to do it.
So are you going to do it?
Um,
I don't know. I'm feeling pretty
good. I don't like going at this.
I don't like going to the doctor that way.
I don't like one to the fucking mall.
I just,
the whole idea of going over there and
parking and just the whole fucking thing.
I know. I need feel the shower. Make sure
you show up 15 minutes before. Oh yeah.
Y'All be there. See that?
I know. But once it's done,
it's done. And you need all my
first show in Hollywood, Florida.
There was a couple of
ladies in the front row.
Uh, we're asking if you were there
because they needed relationship advice.
Oh yeah. You know, so they were like,
how come we don't have boyfriends?
No, they didn't say this.
That's what they said.
Someone actually wrote me and asked me
about you proposing and actually that's
what I wanted to do.
I wanted to talk about this email I got,
should we do it today or should we
do it day to fuck his writing you on?
How the fuck are they writing you?
Because they write Mike because of
my website tender headed films.com.
So they were writing me because remember
I was going to do a podcast all those
years ago and then they just never did it.
No,
they wrote this whole thing about how did
you get a guy who was so anti marriage
to propose and all that kind of stuff
and how did it happen and did I propose?
No, I did not propose. But he'll
propose to me. Uh, and all that stuff.
It was interesting. I did, excuse me.
No, no. See this is why we have to talk
about it. Cause that's some bullshit.
Oh wait, even put that out there. I got
a joke. We have fucking relaxed down.
You love me. You missed me. You
told [inaudible] story. Now,
one thing about show business
is you leave them wanting more.
So get your fucking cute ass
outta here. All right, goodbye.
I want to talk about that story there.
I want to answer.
We all want to do things in life.
Beat it. Goodbye. Hit the road
jack. Don't you come back?
No, no, no. Oh, hit the road. Deni yeah,
so that's what I came up to.
She fucking shows me this big goddamn
thing about all the fucking mic.
Granted them as much as I'm going to bitch
it. It was a bunch of fucking larvae.
I swear to God. She says that
comes from apples in flowers,
in a flower and flower being left out
and grains what? App? You know what?
If you agree with her, you can go fuck
yourselves. How about that? All right,
let's read a little advertising here
for this week, shall we? Oh my goodness.
MVMT watches, you know,
it's been a few weeks now.
Um,
since they started advertising movement,
watches boxes and Oh my God,
what the f,
I don't even understand this copy.
As promised,
the quality of these watches are there
for an awesome price in the style
department.
The compliments that you'll get wearing
these things are really unbelievable.
You know what I'm doing?
I gotta start this over again.
This is what I'm doing is they keep
fucking having me say that I cracked open
these boxes and I'm fucking
wearing one right now and I'm not.
So it fucks up all the copy. All
right. I will read what you write,
but I'm not going to start lying saying
I have on your fucking underwear.
You'll watch is one I doubt. Listen
these. All right, let me start over again.
So they don't hear that part cause
they don't, they don't. Well listen,
that fucker apart. They just
listened to the read. All right.
Unless one of you cats rats me out on
Twitter like the fucking j Edgar Hoover is
everybody's acting like nowadays.
All right. MVMT watches.
If you haven't had a chance to experience
how a movement watch fits around your
wrist while God dammit,
this is your chance movement watches
start at just $95 seat when movement cut
out the middle man with
huge big brand markups,
the price of a stylist watch
finally got affordable.
Imagine that a watch with department
store quality for a fraction of the price
movement has grown organically
purely by supporters like you.
So join there more than 1 million social
media followers and get a movement
watched today. Uh, please
spell it. MVMT okay,
go to Mv Empty Michael Victor,
Michael,
Tom watches.com/burr and they'll give you
15% off your entire purchase purchase.
That's M v empty watches.com/burr.
All right.
Helux or helix.
What is it about buying a mattress
that leaves you feeling violated?
This, that's not a good word
to use with the mattress. Um,
is it the pushy salespeople,
the fake presidents' Day
sales or the fact you know,
you'll regret what you bought,
um,
as you do the walk of shame out of the
mattress store cause you get violated.
Well, what kind of sex offender is
selling you your sheets hallux. He looks,
those days are over.
Thanks to helix sleep well,
you can buy a mattress online customized
for you for hundreds of dollars instead
of thousands. Go to helix, sleep.com.
Answer a few simple questions and Helen's
creates your custom sleep profile to
build you the perfect mattress.
The result,
our customers report a 30%
improvement in overall sleep.
Your mattress will arrive at your door
in about a week and shipping is always
100% free.
Um,
you'll have 100 nights to try
it out and if you don't love it,
they'll pick it up for free and you'll,
you get 100% refund. That's pretty cool,
Huh? That's almost three months. It's
over three months, no questions asked.
It's like it never happened. Uh, if
you do like the new helix mattress,
keep it and your dignity.
That's why everyone from Gq magazine to
Forbes are all talking about helic sleep.
Go to helix,
sleep.com/burr and get $50 off your order.
That's helic sleep.com/burr.
Hey,
he likes sleep.com/ [inaudible] one
of those pronunciations is right.
All right, dollar shave
club, everybody, all my God,
look who's back dollar shave club.
They're all a shave club.com as a special
offer for new members who join today,
you'll get a free month of the executive
razor when you buy a tube of Dr
Carver's shave butter. I swear to
God, it used to be easy shave butter.
This is the first time they've ever done
something like this and once you try
dollar shave club.com you'll become a
proud member like millions of others.
One reason is because they deliver amazing
raters razors right to your door for
a third of the price of what the
greedy razor corporations charge.
That means when you
joined dollar Shave Club,
you can afford to shave with a
fresh blade anytime you want,
which feels fantastic.
You'll get a first class shave when you
use the executive blade hurting your
wallet.
Another reason is that Dr cabbies ac shape
by using it with the executive razor,
the blade just glides gently for the
smoothest shave ever. Dr Carver's.
Shave butter isn't your
average shave cream.
It's a unique conditioning for me though
with high quality natural ingredients
leading your skin,
feeling unbelievably smooth and soft and
right now new members who buy a two of
shea butter get the executive
razor for absolutely free.
They'd never done this before.
Take advantage of it or you'll regret it
for the rest of her life and it's only
available by going to doctors.
Dollar Shave club.com/bar that's
dollar shave club.com/bar and lastly,
but certainly not leastly
are old friends@stamps.com
as America celebrates the
national small business week this week.
stamps.com wants to honor not only,
it's over 600,000 small
business customers.
stamps.com also wants to
extend an invitation to every
small business throughout
the nation to help their business succeed
by reducing or eliminating wasteful
trips to the post office.
stamps.com knows that one of your most
valuable resources as a small business is
time.
You can't waste it making constant
goddamn trips down to the post office for
mailing and shipping.
That's why stamps.com brings all of the
services of the post office right to
your desk. Buy and print official US
postage for any letter, any package,
any class of mail using your computer
and printer over 600,000 small businesses
are already using stamps.com and
you know what you should too.
I use stamps.com anytime of sending out
any stupid posters or whatever bullshit
I'm trying to sell after my
shows if I can figure it out.
So can you right now you sign up
for stamps.com and use my last name,
birth for this special offer,
four week trial plus a $110 bonus offer
that includes postage and a digital
scale. Don't wait. Go to stamps.com
before you do anything else,
click
on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinbirththatstamps.com
enter
ber. Ah Right. And with
that it's over. Come on,
come on now.
Delete.
Close the window and onto
the rest of the bullshit.
I had the worst.
Fucking keeps a good guy.
But I had a bad cab driver on the
way back from the fucking airport.
Use One of those, uh, one of those people
that can't keep a consistent speed,
you know,
so they make your car sick.
And what was hilarious was he was driving
a Prius and the way he was driving
this thing, I would be surprised
if he was getting an eight count,
eight miles per gallon. He
just kept doing that. Yeah.
Eh,
just stomp and glide. Um, I can,
I just amazing to me some people
like how they cannot hear,
you can't hear the engine,
you know,
he can't hear the fucking
rpms going through the roof.
You don't understand that as wasting fuel.
I don't,
you know how bad those
cabbies get fucked over.
You think that he would be concerned
about something and you think if you drove
for a fucking living, you'd have an
understanding of how fucking works.
Um, it was so fucking
annoying. It actually,
it just Kinda just became funny and
he was a really nice guy. But, um,
I don't know.
Some people like it's almost like,
it's like they're driving
with a fake foot, you know,
or a mechanical foot like the prototype
and then, you know, it's either on or off.
There's no, um, consistency
of speed. This guy,
he just kept going up to like 65,
70 miles an hour and then glide
back down to like, you know, 52.
Of course I'm looking at my fucking
phone, some starting to get six. Yeah.
You know, it was, it was a shit show,
an absolute fucking shit show or,
you know,
when I went to Florida,
by the way,
I landed in Miami every
time I land into my Miami,
oh you immediately start seeing all
these beautiful women and every time I go
there I just hear Tony
Montana voice going.
The city is like one big
pussy waiting to get fucked.
MMM.
And I was trying to bait me into those
two women that was sitting in the front
row to get into that fucking conversation.
Um, but she didn't buy the
bait. She didn't take the bait
cause they were like,
why don't we have boyfriends?
You know when you should have seen
him cause I dunno cause you guys are,
you're not wearing any clothes
that be,
the one thing is beautiful as you are.
No guy wants to put up with that.
You got to walk down the street
like some overprotective dog.
I am keeping everybody
away. Everybody's, we,
one of them was barely wearing a shirt.
Granted I wasn't complaining
for where I was standing front,
but I mean it just seemed kind of
obvious. You know what I mean? You got it.
You've got to cover up
the goods a little bit.
I mean I would say that to Madonna.
I don't know if she's currently
dating somebody right now,
but Mcdonald's and fucking unbelievable
shape for her age and if she would just
put on something elegant,
you know what I mean?
Still a rolling around with half
a fucking pussy lip hanging out.
I don't know why she does that.
She said something late, you know,
as she did yet another thicker,
all fucking career's been like one big
publicity stunt after another. You know,
I'm wearing a wedding dress,
but I'm fingering myself
at the fucking award show.
Right. You know, right from
there. And then, oh, it's Jesus,
but he's African American and
now I'm trying to fuck them.
It's just paint by numbers.
Shock. And what's funny is
I actually liked her music.
I just keep,
you know,
that's actually how I threw out my back
doing that Molly Ringwald dance. Um,
anyways, yeah. And then she
goes on Letterman. She says,
fuck 50,000 times.
She does stand up on the tonight show
was just one big fucking thing after
another. So our latest one was, she showed
up to a movie theater and I moved, Oh,
movie premiere,
whatever the Fuck Shit.
I don't know who the fuck
knows what it was, you know,
some fundraiser to get toothbrushes
to some fucking God's forsaken place.
So she shows and she literally has her
teddies and harass out like a see through
dress. And she of course says, well,
what I'm doing is I'm challenging
the boundaries and um,
you know, of course women, you know,
you've got to drag all that bullshit.
And then it's like, no, you're 57 okay.
Nobody wants to look at that. Okay.
Like it my h I.
M I am willing to put on a fucking sport.
Yeah.
Coat
what he wants to see it. It's just a,
yeah, you're not pushing any boundaries.
It's just, it's a a, you know, you have
it. A little bit of a midlife prices.
I think she looks fucking great, but
she'd look way better if she fucking just,
you know,
you don't put on sprout a fucking dress.
Fucky I've, I dunno. But then again,
I saw Iggy pop and he
wasn't wearing a shirt,
but I don't find guys aren't
like attractive. It was
just sort of funny to me.
Not Funny.
I just was just him not giving a fuck.
So I guess if she just said,
look, I don't give a fuck.
I just fell a cabin my ass
and titties hanging out.
I wouldn't have a problem with that.
But put the fact that she's sitting
there trying to say that, no, no.
Wait a minute. I think she might
be right. Maybe she is right.
Hey, come here. You got
to answer this question.
There's a chance I might be common
life and understand the dawn of war
until she comes here. I'll sing a
sing some of my favorite songs by her.
A bad boy.
Bad girl home by six,
eight. Pick up the mic.
I got a question for you
now.
You want me back?
Yup. That's like that street
joke I told you. Right.
Watch when I heard Jackie
the joke, man, tell
the one about the gorilla.
No,
the one with the fucking
cause I liked that one.
The married guys walking out of the
house and his wife's yelling at him,
don't get the fuck outta here. Get the
fuck out. I never want to see you again.
So he's walking away and she goes,
I hope he had died a long, slow,
miserable death. And he turns around.
He goes, oh, what now you want me back?
That's stupid. That's a stupid joke.
Just reminded me of that. Anyway, school,
I could have told it better,
but I got to,
I just got off plink Jackie junk man
tells a way better. Um, all right,
so McDonogh recently borderline,
um, she showed up at some fucking,
you know, raise awareness thing.
I don't know what it was.
It was a carpet she showed up and she
had a butt cheeks out in a titties out.
Okay. This was the met ball that
happens every year in New York City.
And that's for the mets.
Yes, it is. Go math, but it's
just for wonderful. I know.
It's for the fucking museum.
Yes. The hacky date. Every person
in that twenties goes on in New York
and Madonna, let's go to a museum. Um,
it's a big gala and made the
Creme de Creme Darling. I invaded.
So Ralph Lauren pretends to fall.
He sniffs or butter and the way down.
So what happens? Well, you
know, this super rich people,
they're all freaks. They wasn't
at the point of eyes wide shut.
I don't know what the point
of eyes wide shut was.
What happened was Stanley Kubrick died.
He died halfway through.
I saw a great fucking movie on a plane
called the insiders. It's a movie made by,
uh, some Korean director. Man.
It was fucking phenomenal.
Really enjoyed it.
Okay.
Had One of the best fucking
fight scenes that I, I've seen,
cause the guy was missing her head,
you know, so he had to like fucking,
you know, everybody knew one
handy was throwing right.
And it was multiple attackers.
It was the shit.
I almost gave it a standing
ovation on the plane.
If it was pre nine 11 I could have done
it. But I started to do and they're like,
sorry
I had to sit down and okay,
it's another freedom lost.
So anyways,
so fucking,
but Donna shows up. Yes. Okay.
So she says that she's trying to fucking
push the boundaries of whatever the
fucking sex and that type of thing.
Yeah. Okay. So I was going like, no,
c'mon, you're 57 no wants to see
me without a shirt on grants.
She's in better shape than I, but like,
you know, Almond must my sport coat year,
like, you know, covered
up their freckles. Right.
So what I'm saying is you're in your
sport coat you yeah, yeah, yeah.
You get to a certain point, you get
to your forties and stuff like that.
Women Dress elegantly. And men dress like
gentlemen. Yeah. In other words, yeah.
You cover up,
uh,
you know the fucking battle scars
of what you've been through can too.
When he fucking wine and cheese plates.
No,
what I'm saying is, so I was saying with
Mark Madonna, just put on a nice dress.
You could look really elegant. Right.
That's not really her vibe. Yeah, I know.
I know. But you know something. It's
like you look even, who's kidding who?
Michael Jackson, he, if he
was still alive, the short
pants with the glitter socks.
It's like, come on dude. Some point
you've got to update the look. What is it?
What is your point? Let this
hall and Madonna thing. So
I was, I was saying that,
but then I was like, wait a minute. But
when I saw Iggy pop with no shirt on,
I thought it was bad ass that daddy
didn't give a fuck site. That's,
that's bullshit. So I should be actually
applauding Madonna. Wow. Look at you.
See that? That's not, that's not okay. I
was going to say, you're going like, wow,
look at you. You're really not as
dumb. So my apologies to Madonna
fee is like, I'm sure take it.
Look at my fucking 57 year old
kid tds teas.
She's my age with tense.
She's 10 years, we're 10 years
apart. So she's 50 wait, what?
Madonna? 57 years. Wait is she, is she
was born in the same area as prince?
Oh Shit. Oh, same year as Michael Jackson.
Michael Jackson was 58
prince was 58 and take,
but Donna was 58 I never
know how old Madonna is ever.
And that was like in 1957 Oh my God,
you're right. She's going to be 58 right?
Had no idea. And August, yeah,
she'll be 58 so 1958 as far as
music goes was kind of like 1943
1943 was Janis Joplin,
Jimi Hendrix and Jim Morrison
all born 1943
and then they all died in 1970 and then
people started to understand drugs and
you know, bringing a jump rope on
the road and maybe becoming a Vegan.
So now that they live longer and
Michael made it to 50 prints,
made it to 57 but don is still going okay.
Right.
So all of them in their own way kind
of went on stage with their ass hanging
out. Right. Um, okay.
Are you going to fill up
an hour? I gotta fuck it.
I want to do some questions here.
Okay. Say you brought me into,
show me that you've evolved and
seeing your own. Oh, I was trying,
I was trying to see if that was a double
standard women and showing their bodies
and you know,
double standard also works with women
the way they look at guys in certain
situation to what you guys
aren't like perfect. No one,
no one is claiming to be
perfect to media just seems to
cover your complaints.
And then this just told
you ever have a voice.
Thank God you have this podcast.
I know. No one would hear me. Okay,
listen, you got to understand
the world doesn't live with me.
They don't have the privilege of
living with me the way you do.
So I need to do this once a week.
That's a fucking beautiful watch. Who
got you that? You did? That's right.
Asshole response to stinky
German from last week.
So this poor bastard,
he's German, right? Yes. And
uh, so he lives in Germany.
He's old school. He didn't
leave and try to be like, hey,
I wasn't part of that Hitler thing.
Right. He still has his grandparents
said, you know, I don't know if it's me,
but this guy's making a lot of sense.
So,
so because of the mistakes
for fathers and mothers,
the gods have cursed him that he just
sort of smells a little musty and he's
cheese tries showering, it has all this
shit. He doesn't know what the fuck to do.
So evidently this,
this and this other musty guy,
formerly musty guy heard about this.
Okay.
Does he look into his diet? Yeah, we do.
We talked about that and how it ptosis
and maybe have a fucking as a sinus
infection. I don't know what, but
he just, he just smells bad. Yeah.
No matter how matter how much he
shower. So this guy says, yeah,
he wears deodorant. Yeah. It
was quite, it's quite a mystery.
Boy,
I tell you that,
Whoa, this person is in response to
this. This is a formerly musty person,
so I hope this helps
the, uh, the Sauerkraut.
Oh,
Jesus.
That is my best fucking fun ever.
I'm sorry.
Shit was great. All that was pretty good.
That was bad. Was good. That was good.
That was good. All right.
I'm gonna. I'm gonna.
He said,
I'm gonna and keep this simple because
we all know of you're reading issues
would, I admittedly have,
I've been a fan for years,
but this is the first time I feel
the need to chime in on something.
Last week you read a question from a
German guy that had a musty body odor and
did not know what to do about
it. He said, growing up,
I dealt with the same bullshit
that poor SAP is going through.
I always smelled musty. I could not wash
it away, no matter how often I showered.
This is brutal.
I feel bad for these people.
I tried everything and
finally realized it was,
it was antiperspirant
for some weird reason.
My Body reacted when I put
it on and I smelled musty.
I actually stopped wearing deodorant
for a few weeks in the winter,
so I did not smell like a complete savage.
After that period of time,
I began wearing deodorant only
skipping all brands with anti person.
Uh, happily the stinky,
musty odor went away.
Hope this works. You Stinky
Fuck, love the podcast.
Your comedy and F is for family
and go fuck yourself. Yeah,
so basically what I got from that is
maybe his body is having a reaction to
something that he is using. I don't
know. Cause your body should sweat.
It's the way to keep you cool. Right.
That's the whole point of sweating.
So antiperspirant,
I know maybe people who sweat excessively,
they don't want to be sweating
through their clothes or something.
So I don't know. But it sounds
like that person to go to a doctor.
Well they haven't been able to figure
out what's going on and he's in Germany
too and those guys don't fuck around over
there. They're very efficient. Yeah. No
cars. The trades, the
rocket side trick, you know,
everybody could just forgive him
for that one crazy 10 year period.
I think they got a little
sideways. They'll never,
they'll never live it down. No,
you can't. Sorry. You know what?
It's on video. That's quite,
you know, other countries could do shit.
And it happened before like a certain,
something that happened in 1915
that we always see advertised. Uh,
my vote dear bill on Capitol Hill
and I know what you're talking about.
Well you should,
you know what if there was movie cameras
around you with movie cameras? Yup.
Motion picture things.
Have you ever heard of vermin supreme?
Um, he's been on, I, I don't,
I don't believe that this is somebody
whose name I'm going to look this up
before you guys make a fool of me,
which is not hard to do.
Why don't you read it first?
Because then I start commenting and then
halfway through I realize it's a prank
phone call. Vermin
supreme. It's coming up.
Vermin Supreme Vermin supreme
as an American performance.
Ardor artists and activists who has
run as a candidate and very low various
local states. Um, okay,
let me see what this,
what's up with this guy? Okay.
I never heard of this guy.
He's been on the ballot in New Hampshire
and his platform has a lot to do with
dental health. He also has a plan
in place for the Zombie Apocalypse,
which involves setting up thousands of
treadmills to put the zombies on to help
power the new world. He wears
a giant boot on his head. Oh,
I've seen this fucking guy.
That boot that's right,
and carries around a rubber toothbrush.
Here's an article on him.
He also has promised free
ponies for everyone. Oh,
so he's a whack job.
I don't know if he's a whack job because
that's a really funny joke though.
The zombies on the treadmill. Are
you looking them up? Are you texting?
I was looking at Madonna photos.
Okay.
We were back here and we've now,
we moved on. We've moved on,
but I had just was still looking
at photos. I'm here. Don't preach.
I mean trouble. Dino
happened, Dope Madonna songs.
I just said, I'm sorry. I did my
fucking, I did see your, your, your,
your vocal warmups. Yeah. This was
not a good luck at the met ball.
It was just I, yeah. Oh ladies,
can we stick together? First of all, it's
got something. I'm right
at home, but now it's not.
I'm not being catty. She
just, it's just so thirsty.
It's just, I don't, and I love Madonna,
but this is just too
much. I get done. Yeah,
I'm done. Sure. I'm
sure her kids enjoy, uh,
wife's family is a bunch
of dramatic babies. Oh God.
You're the baby. And we go, hey
bill, I'm sick of this election.
I hope Trump wins. I know he's
a jerk, but I hate Hillary.
I think Bernie is a nice guy without
a clue. He says a lot of great things,
but he's going to raise taxes. He talks
about making college free, but his taxes,
we'll make it hard. Nothing is free.
Yeah, that's never going to happen.
But I think that, you know, free health
care, it's not, this is not free.
Somebody has got to fucking pay for it.
He talks about making college free,
but it's taxes will make it harder for
people like me to pay my student loans.
I make 95 grand a year.
I have a kid,
a hundred grand in student loans between
me and my wife, we live comfortably.
But if you take another 20 $504,000
from him a year, I will feel it.
Yeah, definitely. I am already
only netting 60. What is
the fuck is all of this?
What's the point?
The family has adventure.
Dramatic babies.
Okay.
All right. Blah, blah, blah, blah.
MMM.
Okay. So we're getting to, we're getting
to a family here somewhere. Okay.
I'm not opposed to giving money to help
people who need it, but when is enough?
Enough, $1 trillion on dumb shit
every year. And you need more from me.
Fuck off Bernie. I love how
he's blaming Bernie. You know,
if Bernie didn't create
the fucking situation, um,
he's trying to get us out of it. I guess.
I don't know if it's going to work.
I don't think, I mean, I don't know if
people will work with the guy, but oh God,
what a fucking decision this year.
Um, so I make this point to my wife,
my wife's family. I didn't yell. I
didn't say fuck off Bernie. I just said,
I don't think we,
the people should have to give more
money if they're wasting the money they
already get. Well, my wife's
family lost their shit.
They said that I'm selfish
and that if I vote for Trump,
I'm endorsing hate and greed and fascism,
a really question mark. They endorsed
Obama and I have a problem with him.
Hatefully blowing up kids and
wedding parties with drones.
Why doesn't that make them hateful?
Uh,
they then went on to talk about for
30 minutes about hate and how theirs,
they were scared about what would happen
to the country and they're scared about
how children would grow
up in a country with,
and I quote Hitler minus
the concentration camps.
I told him that comparing an Egomaniac
to Hitler is unfair to the victims of the
Holocaust.
It trivializes the actual evil of Hitler.
Hitler embodied her mother and father
were both taken it back and said that my
way of thinking could potentially
be dangerous to their grandchildren.
What period the fuck period is going,
period on period. Well, you're dope.
Yeah. You fucking opened up your
fucking mouth of Bob's politics.
No, he isn't. He's young. He doesn't
know. Well, what's now, you know,
how did you learn? How did you learn
and how did I learn by bringing it out?
By doing that? Yeah. This is the deal.
Yeah. You know, you can't talk, talk
about politics and religion and shit
like that. Those are going to say it got,
it got really heated right
before they said that shit. Well,
you can't, and also he just, he
can't, I don't know. He got to,
if you really
are going to vote for Trump,
I just,
I think there's only certain sections
of the United States where you could say
that where you'll get a, yeah, I get it.
Oh, well tell me more about your opinion.
I feel like if you say, you know
what, fuck this, I'm voting for Trump,
most people are going to be like,
are you fucking kidding me?
So I'm not surprised at that,
but no. Yeah, you really,
a lot of shit. And I was,
I made fun of him when, uh, you
know, I got some shit for it.
For making fun of Trump. Yeah. From
whole people who support Trump.
Oh, well, okay, fine. Yeah,
they have, believe it or not,
this people that she has a lot
more than I thought. Remember when,
when he was first talking about
running and we're both like,
this is never going to happen.
This is a joke. This is ridiculous.
And now here we are and he's like
the only Republican left standing.
So I mean, I guess I underestimated
him and he's like the last home party.
He's like the Leicester City of Pollock
politicians. But here's the thing,
I family. But I think like, you know,
Hillary Clinton is the fucking devil
because she's acting like she gives a fuck
and she's, you know, she's one of those
Bilderberg people. I don't like her.
I like Bernie out of all of them.
I liked Bernie Sanders.
I just don't think anybody's
going to fucking work with, well,
the California primary is coming up,
so he's,
he's not thrown in the towel with Ernie,
but we got to Ireland.
I am.
I have to vote for a person that I feel
is actually truly gives a shit about
regular people and that would
be him. Whether he's going
to be successful or not.
And I know what a lot of people,
wholesaler,
you're going to put Trump good old office.
I've always voted for the fucking third
wheel. Every fucking God damn time. Well,
when the primary happens,
we got to vote for him.
That's the only way that he'll listen.
I don't have to do anything that you say.
Okay. But uh, I don't know what
I'm going to do. So basically his,
this guy's in law, you know,
we just did. We just did.
We just did with this guy did,
which is what we just fucking
talked politics and it
gave endorsements to Bernie
said,
we shouldn't have done that.
I still haven't made up my
mind that I'm going to do that.
Why are we were giving endorsements
just by talking about it,
by saying that you're going to do it.
Well, that's how I feel like that guy,
that fuck, we're like those, those people
that you see on Facebook and they go,
Hey,
do you know me?
I pretend to be a doctor on his soap
opera and I think this is who you should
vote for. I apologize
for that people. I, I,
I tried not to say that eventually she
was going to come up doors seeing anybody
weird. Well, let's just
leave it. I'll tell you what.
I'm endorsing a nice fucking
cold Budweiser. When I sit
down to watch game five
doors, what is, what does he want to know?
He is just sort of like, what the hell?
Now My,
now my inlaws don't want
me to have children with my
wife because they think I'm
evil and they're going to,
I'm going to raise a little evil.
Trump's might think about Trump is his
fucking lack of compassion for fucking
people.
When you sit there and say take his coat
and like riling people up like that was
just says that he says
really awful things,
but the thing I like about him is he
lets me know that they actually count the
votes because no super rich
people want that fucking guy.
And I always thought for years
my conspiracy theory is like,
they don't count these fucking things.
They do. Oh, it's pretty fucking close.
And they put the money on both horses
and then, then the fucking fine. But uh,
the fact that he's actually doing well,
he's speaking a lot of people out there
needing, it's going to build a wall.
He's going to have the people
he's walling and pay for it,
felony these talking mad shit.
And now I feel like I,
all those years of watching the apprentice
and the celebrity apprentice are now
coming back to when you tried to find
a CEO for a company that doesn't exist.
It's all coming back
to bite me in the ass.
I've been supporting him
this whole entire time.
I'm partly to blame for this boss Shit.
So what does this look?
He can't be a complete moron. What does
this kid saying? What does this point?
He's just is, no, he's
just saying what the fuck.
So we just will not talk about politics
anymore around your inlaws, Huh?
Tell you that much. But then he said,
looking forward to seeing you in Dublin,
myself and some friends that will
be coming from Belfast. Well,
I'm going to be doing Belfast
too, so you don't even, yeah,
you don't even need to do that. Yeah.
I were putting together the dates,
so I'm definitely doing Dublin.
Definitely doing Belfast.
I'm doing a little 10 day tour over there,
cause skin.
It's not a good time to go to Scandinavia
this time of year because they
actually have sunlight and it's
warm out, so when I usually, well,
because they're going to want
to be outside. Okay. Yeah.
Yeah.
If you go in December and it's already
fucking dark and go to movies and stuff,
still though,
I would imagine just cause it's sunlight
most of the time doesn't mean why would
I listen to the promoters over
there? I'll listen to it. All right.
When is this happening?
I'm going to go.
That's going to be happening and to Jill
like I think it's going to start on the
31st and it's going to go into August.
Very excited about that.
Exciting things are happening.
I love Ireland. I know.
I love the people in Ireland.
Look who you're with. Oh,
potato face himself here and vice
with neighbors emotionally. German,
all mighty Billy.
I don't,
I actually don't even know that cause I
never done the whole La [inaudible] is
like a more German than Irish cause I
am Jeremiah Irish Catholic podcasts.
It doesn't get any wider. Doesn't
get it. Doesn't get any wider, right.
All mighty Billy Ball bag. Ah, all
right. And vice with neighbors. Question.
I live in an apartment complex here in
the lovely state of Oklahoma and I have
this neighbor who lets her dog
out on her balcony every morning.
Somewhere between the hours
of four and 5:00 AM oof.
The dog barks aggressively
for hours afterward.
Of course it wakes me up.
Poor thing.
The dog that is and this about this poor
bastard or lady Oklahoma in Oklahoma
and Oklahoma in
am Oklahoma. Oh sexual. No.
Isn't that one of the characters
on your Nashville show?
I want to write a song with you.
Lax about us.
They gay cowboy, the gay cowboys to
gay cowboys. Cutting edge character.
That's the first gay cowboy ever
in primetime in Bram time. Yes.
Prime time during the lunch hour.
It was just littered with
them when I was growing up.
Those people on Captain Kangaroo, right?
Ernie and Bert isn't what they said.
All those guys. Right.
All right, question.
I live in an apartment complex here in
the lovely state of Oklahoma. Okay. Yeah.
The dog barks aggressively for hours.
It wakes me up and I have to go.
I have to work at 8:00 AM I filed
complaints after an altercation in which I
went out and scream, shut your fucking
dog up before I make you shut him up now.
Was that your opening line now or
something along those lines? My mess.
My message has not been
heard by the apartment cons
and she continues to let the
dog out. What should I do?
Sincerely, a blue collar working man,
just trying to get some fucking
sleep. Who's the soup? Also?
Saint Louis Blues gave the stars
of fucking Molly whopping today.
Hope you watched it. I missed that. Um,
well fuck gear and you're in Oklahoma,
man. You know what she need to do?
Take out your side iron.
Hey, hey, hey, hey, eh,
take the fucking dog outs.
The bill plow.
Don't even joke about it with rubber
bullets. Don't even check about that.
Who is your super?
No,
he put rubber bullets in the gun and
every time the dog barks, I resigned.
The dog barks. You shoot it
and its ass and it starts, oh,
when I bark and then I'll shut
up. Now you can't do that. Uh,
you would get arrested for that.
So why don't I would just go down.
I would buy a month's worth
a cube. Steaks. All right.
Why does it,
does the dog shit and Piss on the balcony?
Is that why she's letting it out there?
Cause that's gross. I don't know.
But that is so fucking not acceptable
because you know it's probably the fucking
dog gets up at four at 5:00 AM it's
keeping her up or him up. So they,
oh my God. No, it's you gotta you gotta
call them on or something. I'll wait.
Did he say that they're not
paying attention at the,
like we say it's not going over well
with the people in the apartment?
Well he has like, she just has a
neighbor. I can't, I don't think I was,
it's an apartment complex.
Yeah.
You got to say something to the
management company. Oh look,
there's no fucking way. He's the
only person that's ignored by this.
Of course I would go around and I would
get a bunch of signatures and then I
would, you know, try to have everybody
all get together and say, uh,
that bitch needs to shut
the other bitch. Oh, oh,
oh no.
What's up buddy?
Okay.
Yeah. This will be like, it's time
for this one probably to go out.
Speaking of all that. All
right, well you do that. Well,
I will wrap up the podcast here. No,
you take it around. I took my survey.
It was a Jacksonville this morning. That's
my, uh, that's my excuse. All right,
well that's going to be
the, uh, the lay down. Wait,
so we didn't offer any advice
besides, you're a horrible
joking advice. Of course.
I just said, dude, get
a bunch of signatures.
You can get enough signatures
is not going to do shit.
You got to go to the
management company and be like,
this dog is barking at four or five
in the morning every morning. Oh,
he said he already did that. Oh,
a narrow. Not Paying attention.
You said he's in this fucking, what do
you think signatures are going to do?
A technology like to hear about? Oh no,
that's not it. Oh wait, I missed one.
Okay.
He said, I have this name. I live in an
apartment complex. The dog barks. I've,
I filed complaints. Yeah. Like
nothing's happening that sacks. Wow,
you have to do this thing. I'm not going
to pay my fucking rent. There you go.
I'm not paying my rent until you get this
woman to shut this damn dog. Oh yeah.
Cause that's not fair.
Yeah, she's lived there.
That sounds like something an older
person would do to just like put their dog
out on the balcony and just let it bark
all morning because it probably goes
out, takes a piss, takes a shit,
and then wants to come inside
and meanwhile the owner
has gone back to sleep.
All right, well obviously I was joking.
You don't shoot what the doc? No,
you don't. That's right. Clear.
Here's the other one. Um,
all right. Virtual
reality headset. Blow job.
Uh, all right. I know you hate technology,
but we'd like to hear your
opinion on this. My girlfriend,
half jokingly promised me a double
blow job from my 30th birthday.
Okay.
Um,
I do not expect this to happen,
but I have been joking with her that the
date is approaching and she should have
a girl lined up,
et cetera.
I have also been talking about
virtual reality slash Vr headset.
As I'm thinking of getting one, I don't
know what that is. Yeah. What is that?
She asked me the other day, would I be
able to watch porn through it? I said yes.
She then said instead of the double by,
why don't you wear the headset
and I can give you normal.
Oh, by while watching a porno.
What? What are you saying?
Bye. Oh, Bj. Yeah. Oh, you know what?
It was underlined in red,
so I couldn't see the bottom of products.
Like why does this by,
Oh my God, you're really,
skills are atrocious. Yeah.
And by would actually mean that there
wouldn't be a guy and a girl doing it.
I wasn't even, I was thinking about
like his girlfriend would be like by,
because she was down
there with another chick.
I am stupid.
See this people,
Youtube could be successful in life.
You're dumb as me.
She then she then instead of instead
of a double Bj me read this again. Wow.
Why don't you wear a headset and I could
give you a normal BJ while watching a
porno. Why can't you do that now with
a TV? Because I feel like when they,
I'm like weird tron futuristic shit.
When you put it on this opening Pandora's
box or is this a way for Vr to be seen
as a techie sex toy? You are really
asking the wrong person that question.
You know, Bill doesn't know. We're
looking forward to see you in Dublin.
Myself and some friends will be
coming from belts. Oh this is the I,
that was the one. Okay.
Um, is this the same?
I read the ending to the other one to
that one and it was weird because the
ending was in front of the other one.
Oh fuck you and fuck everybody
else. Yeah. Big. It's all funny.
It's all fun and games. Until
I stopped podcasting. Ah, Oh,
I've had enough of this sensitive.
Uh, no I'm not, I don't care. Um,
it is a slippery slope, but I feel
like that could be really kind of cool.
Does she get to do it too?
Like does she get to watch some porn?
Why you like go down on her? That'd
be really trippy. It would be trippy.
But the thing is then,
then what ends up happening is,
is then you end up getting
like a that that disconnect.
Right.
And now you don't want to do anything.
That's the one of you is wearing the
helmet. Yeah. It's weird. I'm like, God,
I have to like see you. So that's
all good. It's a dangerous, yeah.
That's like one of those things like do
you think I could do however one once
and like be all right with
that now I saw something,
I'm
trying to think where I saw it.
Saw what in one of those Asian countries,
because they're always ahead of us. They
have better cell phones. There was a, uh,
a guy trying out like a
virtual reality sex suit,
which I had a bit on this
thing in like the uh,
late nineties when I first heard that they
were going to do that. And by the way,
the fact that you haven't already
called me outgoing, like bulk bill,
how did you just stumble upon
this? I'm dead honest. What?
I don't remember for the rest of the
story cause I felt like there was more,
it could have been while I was
watching Internet porn probably. Yeah.
But they don't have advertising
advertisers for that.
It was like a story on
the side of the thing.
They have all those and how do you
know that? Yeah, right back at you.
So yeah, but they don't have
any, don't have ads like that.
Right. That's true. Well,
this is what it was. It looked
like a fucking dude. He was like,
let a mummy suit who's hilarious.
He was all wrapped up in toilet paper,
but that's how I remember it because
it was so horrifying. It was just,
it was one of those things, whatever I
was looking at that came up and I went,
wow. Right. And it looked like
mmm.
His hands went to his side. He
had on the fucking, you know,
I'm old and I can't see anymore.
Those glasses,
those cataract glad cataract
glasses from the drugstore. Yeah,
so he had on those,
I think it was all wrapped up because he
didn't want anybody to see who he was.
Maybe that's what it was.
And then there was this thing,
obviously his dick was in
it. Oh my God. And it just,
the same way your hand would be going like
bang, Bang, Bang, Bang against yourself.
It was this thing.
It was the most fucked up thing ever.
Would you ever use one of
those flash bought things.
You know how porn stars they get
home old are so fucking gross.
I think those things,
those things are so fucking gross.
A long time ago I did somebody podcast.
I'm not gonna say who,
but people who listen
to podcasts, no. Who is,
he had one of those things and it looks
like some Jeffrey Dahmer body part.
No automatically who you're talking just
sitting. I don't think you'd do. Oh okay.
Cause I know who you're going to guess.
But it wasn't that person. Um, it looked,
no, it just looked like
and it, did he say that it,
did it feel like a re it can't feel like
a real vagina obviously, but like it,
if it's just, it's, I,
I can't believe that it does.
Like shit like that doesn't cause
you to either be like become like a
necrophiliac or some sort of perk.
Why would it make you feel necrophilia
cause you're fucking something that looks,
looks like a body part and it's not alive.
Women have like dildos and vibrators and
stuff and it's like the same sensation.
So why wouldn't a one of those
fleshed bought things feel like,
isn't that kind of,
it's just like another Madonna Iggy pop
thing by looking at it the wrong way
maybe? No, I don't think. No, I
don't think you're looking at it.
I remember back in the days,
back in the day,
don't like the idea of a fake vagina.
You don't,
you're not comfortable just sitting on a
table and it has a handle on it and I'm
holding it. No, that's not your thing.
You're not into that feels like
Henry portrait of a serial killer.
I remember back in the day,
right when you actually had to go to a
porno store to get your porn and they had
like, you know, always,
always behind the counter and
they would have shut up there.
It was like what's in the box?
It was literally a head in a box and
the chicks buck was like, all right,
like you stick your Dick in it. You
know like somebody is going to buy that.
Yeah.
It was in like the same box,
like a basketball came in and grab it by
its fucking ears that are stuck to the
side of its head and they're just going
to go home and fuck ahead just to head
now. There's no fucking way
that that doesn't fuck you up.
Psychologically.
If you do that long enough,
then you go out with a real person.
It's already annoying that they have to
buy it dinner and that this is a whole
body attached to it and you have
to talk to it. Yeah, and they all,
they're thinking of just grabbing you by
your ears. Water, water, water. It's over.
Yeah, it's fucked up. Well,
I still feel like we're
going back to the question.
I feel like they can experiment
with it like once or twice,
but it can't be like a regular thing
that they're doing all the time because
then that'll completely fuck up your
sex life because then you'll just be
looking at everything you do. Like
it's supposed to be this hyper reality,
dual reality virtual.
It's just not good,
you know? Fast forward here. Okay.
Now. So that becomes the
thing, right? Which you know,
it's gonna people are gonna do it and
then it's going to become is porn stars
will be making all of that
fucking money and it basically,
you have a girl fucking now they'll
probably just be like the whole suit.
It's eventually just going
to be the whole suit. Right.
What are you talking about?
I'm talking about like in the future,
like when like everybody has
like a virtual reality sex suit.
This will actually help the
population problem, right?
The virtual reality sex suit.
Okay.
And then porn stars will
then have their likeness,
they'll do a POV porn and then they
get money and then you have to like
subscribe.
So you can do a virtual reality thing
where you with any porn star with like
awesome. And then he, and then
here's what happens. Okay.
Who's going to be the first celebrity
that crosses over and eventually,
right,
because they're sick of doing superhero
movies and they don't want to do the
grunt work of an independent cause.
Like you notice now they're all
doing ads over here. Back in the day,
all the celebrities did ads, but
they did him overseas, right.
Remember we used to go over and we all
look at so and so doing a fucking watch
thing or look at her doing this thing,
but they'd never do them here
because there was that whole
stigma that if you did a commercial,
you're a sellout, blah, blah,
whatever the fuck it was.
Or it's like you're doing a commercial,
you're a movie star, movie star. It's
not even on TV. Forget about doing an ad.
Now that all went away,
you know?
So I'm saying eventually
somebody famous would do it,
right. You get that? Yeah.
Get a suit and program it so that you're
having sex with like Lindsay Lohan or
something like that.
And the first one,
the first and the first
level will go down.
Now I'm like one of those
reality TV show stars. You know,
one of the reality show goes off the year,
like Jersey shore. They will all
fucking huge now it's just disappeared.
Why the fuck are they right?
You could probably talk a couple
of them and in doing it right,
we pitched in a show right now
I think,
or some kind of like high tech concept
with that will probably make a lot of
money that's going to end
up having something like a
movie. It sounds like. Like,
uh, what was it that this
is what's going to happen.
You're going to have be self-drive
and fucking cars.
You're going to have self drive and
fucking cars and people are going to be
laying in them in virtual reality suits
having sex with any famous person they
want to write.
And they'll have like,
because you don't need a steering wheel
or gas or brake or anything anymore,
you'll literally feel
like you're suiting there.
And then when you're done your rollover
up from that seat until like another,
like a, uh, like a freshen
up like tub or some shit.
So I think we're totally going in that
direction. I think you're right. We'll,
we'll, we'll see it in the next
generation. Before it was just, yeah,
the fleshbots stuff or just the mold
of the vagina or the deck or whatever.
And then it's going to be this virtual,
it'll be super expensive at first
going to go into a complete,
that's gonna be like one flat screen
TVs first came out and then 14 grants.
So don't buy the first virtual reality
sex suits virtual wait till they come
down to like 800 bucks at best buy.
Then you get them right.
Figure out how to like make
this technology and just
like patent it and that's
how we'll make our,
yeah, we're going to figure out how to do
that. I can't even read copy. We're not
calling it that.
Like that's what's going to happen.
I'm already selling right now
with these self driving cars,
like the interiors of cars.
What they're going to have now,
they're going to have office ones.
They're going to have sleeper ones.
People just want to sleep,
going to work.
They're going to have one second to catch
up on your emails and all of that type
of shit. Yeah, the different those
that'll be like the different, um, the,
the social one,
the social and office one, all of
that type of all, I don't know.
And then eventually it's going to be like,
well,
why are you even going to work now?
Because everything's automated.
Then there's robots,
right?
And then one day the whole
fucking thing just turns on us.
What if there was a company
like in someplace really
random? Not really random.
Like a Japan or, by the way, neither one
of us is high right now. No, not at all.
Completely that high. It's the middle
of the day. Never been more sober.
What if there was a company somewhere
and like, I dunno, not Japan,
but like Eastern Europe that said,
we want to do this deal with you where
we have these like sex dolls with the
your face slot and they offered you like,
yeah,
an insane amount of money.
No, no, to do it. Oh,
and you can buy a bill birth sex to haul.
Do you realize the photoshops I'm going
to get and I'm going to have to re tweak
now.
You asshole.
Oh, you're right. Shit. Oh, they're
going to be horrifying but hilarious.
Like a bill. Birth sex.
Um, what'd you do? Yeah.
They come out of like somewhere
random, like, you know,
Norway or just Sunday or like,
you know,
it's random like Norway, Norway. That's
my random enough like,
you know,
turns mid extend or one of those fucking
places. I'm not even saying it right,
but just a random little pocket
that was just like, you know,
we $5 million that we want to
mix sex toys with your face.
No, you wouldn't go for it.
Can you imagine that phone
call out of nowhere? No.
No I wouldn't. No, I can
honestly tell you that I would.
I know. I know you wouldn't.
Well, yeah, I would think so.
How the fuck did we get all the way over
here, see this wildlife, the questions,
great questions.
Because the person in their
virtual blowjob look worn down by,
according to you.
I never claimed to be smart since
beginning of these podcasts.
I don't know. I, I, I
don't claim to be smart.
And with that go fuck yourselves.
I'm sorry.
The podcast was so late. I was flying
back from Jacksonville. As I mentioned
several times. I complained
about it and, uh,
I'll be checking in on you on Thursday.
I'll see you go blues.